les propositions du gouvernement sur
l'hébergement des sans domicile fixe
n'ont pas entamé la détermination des
enfants de don quichotte il souhaite que
des villages de tentes comme à paris
apparaissent au plus vite dans plusieurs
villes c'est déjà le cas par exemple à
orléans aurélia bon après les bords de
seine les bords de la loire depuis près
de 24 heures les tentes de don quichotte
font partie du paysage d'orléans
ldf mal logés aux militants s'étaient
donné rendez vous hier soir pour passer
une première nuit sous les tentes par
-5° pas suffi l'hébergement d'urgence
maintenant essayons de pérenniser on
fait bien sûr du logement adapté on va
pas faire n'importe quoi pour n'importe
qui mais il ya quand même des gens qui
méritent et ya des gens qui travaillent
et qui n'ont pas de logement pas de quoi
se loger qui sont sur système
d'hébergement d'urgence ne se peut pas
durer ça une exaspération qui gagne peu
à peu les grandes villes en ordre
dispersé chacune tente de s'organiser
pour créer son village de tente
d'ailleurs à lire le site internet des
enfants de don quichotte marseille
grenoble avignon où lille pourrait
accueillir le mouvement dès la semaine
prochaine c'est un mouvement citoyen qui
sont des petits s'autogère qui s'auto
organisent moi je demande à la provence
sincèrement d'aller très très vite pour
camper et moi je me déplaçais pour aller
les voir les esb volontaire de provence
sur le terrain les activistes de droits
au logement sont d'accord avec cette
médiatisation mais il refuse les
méthodes pour eux logés les sdf dans les
tentes n'est pas la solution
le sbf qui est à la rue ça va toujours
être mieux dormir sur le movie de métro
d'avoir un petit toit assemblant de toi
ne serait ce qu'en toile au dessus de la
tête
mais est-ce que son avenir n'est pas
quand même dans une structure en dur
comme tout à chacun
or deux semaines en tout cas l'opération
coup-de-poing des don quichotte aura
lancé le débat est réveillé le monde
politique dans une période de fêtes où
il observe traditionnellement une trêve